a beetlejuice of course for those of you
who are new listeners
we have named in the past beetlejuice
the greatest whack packer of all time
but sadly the last time we saw beat on
this show in person was september of
2016
beat had a new business he had just
started the beat emoji
emojis of course beet had his own emojis
which emoji let's say i want to send
some loving message to my wife beth who
you know
okay you've claimed you banged her i
know you wouldn't do that
oh your wife already knows you already
told me i banged her oh come on
b we're pals and i know you would never
i i won't i want to lie
you go ask her yourself but b i know you
know my wife and you know me many years
what about the bro code you don't mess
with my wife i don't mess with your wife
hey
she asked me to do something for it and
i did it yeah that was a pretty
upsetting appearance actually
when he was in beetlejuice recorded a
bunch of material with richard and sal
that day and like many great talents he
is difficult to work with on occasion
here is a behind the scenes of the day
the last time we saw beetlejuice working
with richard and sal
today's guest i know what today's show
is i ain't [ __ ] stupid just say on
today's show i know what it is i know
what it is
you gotta tell me repeat after me i
ain't gotta repeat at you
i don't wanna [ __ ] know it on today's
show what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
on today's show i know what today's show
is they ain't [ __ ] stupid pal
on the show today i know what else is i
know what it is
what the [ __ ] you keep repeating it you
know
you're funny kind of reminds me when
you're recording your songs you do get a
little bit
out of control you're a bit of a diva
soon after that live appearance
that beetlejuice had with us which we
don't we kind of took for granted we
just figured we'd see beat again
yeah but soon after that appearance
beatle in a shocking move moved in with
his mother in georgia
and beats mother is very protective of
him
so the word in the office was i think
we've seen the last of beetlejuice you
know he's
sequestered but i do have some good news
here beatles manager bobby
as you know beat has a uh he has a lot
of people
in his organization but his manager
manager yeah
his manager bobby visited beat in
georgia
a few weeks ago and bobby gave us an
update
so here it is this is about as much
information as we have on b
according to beetlejuice he's claiming
he had a lot of trouble
contacting us he tried calling you
robin and gary but he claims he couldn't
reach you guys
so here is beat explaining to bobby that
you and gary have been difficult
wow here we go
i tried to call volleyball and shut them
up
we tried calling robin i tried
i tried to call robert but i was
committed
there it is uh well he's probably got an
old number
so bobby says to beetlejuice let me uh
get them on the phone he left us a
voicemail beetlejuice left us at a
voicemail exclusively for us
here it is hey this is beetle
how's everybody in the store hey i quit
smoking man
i've been doing it for my dream month
all right
thank
[Music]
according to bobby b really did quit
smoking and seems really good so it's
not [ __ ]
now i'm gonna blow your mind this is the
big news
for the past few years beat has been
working with some of the biggest names
in hip-hop on a remix of his classic
song
beetle in the house featuring big frida
sean paul and the one and only snoop
dogg
are you kidding me i'm not [ __ ] with
you i'm about to play it
this is where beatles been in the studio
i'm calling this the song of the summer
for 2021
even though it's winter bless them and
there ain't no stressing and sean paul
alongside
big freedom snoop dogg beetlejuice
oh yeah i could do a doggy sound there's
no problem with that
[Music]
the beetlejuice
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you don't know me introducing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
beetlejuice and pull those little
drawers down
and give them some hot head make sure
you get them balls
cause beetlejuice loves when you lick
his balls
ain't that right beetlejuice got big
balls
now give her the juice give her the
juice
the beetlejuice give it the juice
[Music]
that's right and do it
all sucked up nice how great is that
[Music]
amazing